juliana she's just fabulous to work with
we have so much fun together it can be
very daunting going on to another show
it's not yours it's already been
established but i knew jen because we
had worked together and come up together
so it was a very welcome sight for me
she was on er and i was on friends and
our stage is just like a stone's throw
away we used to go out and we'd chat
with each other what was the nature of
your relationship with mitch kessler
seeing laura go toe-to-toe with alex
levy is
really fun because these are women who
have history she's very seasoned sophie
and i our costume designer talked about
making her look a little bit like
katherine hepburn
with the turtleneck and the white shirt
it was important to really define her
the very first time we meet her on
camera and i needed her to have a sense
of authority and feel distinctly
different from the other women on the
show
well if it isn't bradley jackson
yep that's me
i've heard so much about you bradley is
such an infinitely curious person that
she's always pushing to discover more
about herself so it felt so in character
for bradley to be exploring her
sexuality rhys said you never just grab
someone and kiss them whether you're two
women two men
a man and a woman and that's when we did
this sort of choreography where i said
well if i put my hand up to your cheek
and let you know that i'm actually
reciprocating the kiss then it'll be
something that's actually quite
beautiful each character is in their own
world of achievement and ambition and
trying to to get ahead
meanwhile there's this greater force of
nature about to shut everything down and
we're not paying
any attention daniel
we've got to get out of wuhan before 10.
they're locking it down creating wuhan
out of the anaheim train station was
insane but it was so beautifully done
wuhan has one train station that had
kind of an amazing hump and then two
smaller humps and i thought oh my gosh
the new metrolink station in anaheim has
that same sort of shape to it we were
shooting the train station really really
late at night and literally i think the
train had to go off duty so when the
train was done wherever it was
it came to us and in 30 minutes man he
had put up everything and changed the
signs and what looked like just a
regular uh american train became a
trained wuhan
he says we can't tell him who we are
daniel sees kovid first hand he's
ringing the bell and no one is listening
and watching that experience for him in
this moment in time it really feels so
resonant and so relevant and is really
tremendous
[Music]
you